BACK IN MONTREAL.
52 POINTS IN 40 GAMES   -- MATH
IT IN.SHOT, STICK AND BACK
AGAIN AS CHIAROT
KILL OFF SOME MORE TIME.
ZACH ASTON-REESE GOES TO THE  C.
ZUCKER SENDS IT ACROSS. ON THAT
RODRIGUES, LOADS UP,
NET AND LOOK HOW QUICKLY IT GETS
OUT ALL THE WAY TO THE SLOT, TO
THE 2-NOTHING PENS.
COLE CAUFIELD CHIPS IT ALONG THE
BOARDS.
LETANG MOVES IT QUICKLY, HIGH
PENGUINS COMING IN NUMBERS.
LETANG DRIVING PLA VERY SLOW DEO
GET 'ER SS.
CARTER COULD NOT FINISH.
WRIST SHOT, RUHWEDEL ELL CENTRE.
TOUGH TO FIND POSITIVES FOR THIS
HOCKEY C
OF CONFIDENCE WITH THE PUCK,
CHALLENGING PEOPLOR
GUENTZEL.
HE'LL DROP IT OFF.
JUICY
>> Bryan: ANDERSON HAD HIS STICT
DEFENSIVE TEAM.
THEY WILL GIVE YOU OPPORTUNITIES
IF YOU PRESS THEM.
MONTREAL STARTINGNG PASS
OUT OF THE REACH OF SAVARD.HE Q.
>> Bryan: THE
THREE GUYS GET OUTSIDE THE DOTS
ON  : BLUEGER COLLECTS IT.
AND JUST HANGS OUT IN FRO
THERE'S BEEN TOUGH HOCKEY GAMES.
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THAT DRESS E
GALLAGHER.
BRENSTILL HASN'T SCORED THISS
HE'LL SWEEP IT OFFH OF TOFFOLI.
INTO THE FAR NATIVE,
ONE OF THE GREATEST OF ALL  TOO.
>> Bryan: C
LANE.
15 SECONDS REMAINING.
REALLY NICE MOVE IN TIGHT AND A
SIXTH GOAL FOR THE